ميزانيه ميزانيه سنويه تفاصيلها تصنف
كاسرار للدوله وبعيدا عن المسائله لا
تمسها الازمات والتضخم مقومه بالدولار
وسخاؤها ازهر من اشياء كثيره رغم استشراء
الفساد الفوضى في لبنان وسوريا والعراق
واليمن لم تثقل كاهل الدول هذه الدول فقط
فاتوره فاتوره دعم ايراني لميليشياتها
باتت تضاهي ميزانيات دول الكبرى وللمقارنه
يعادل ما تنفقه ايران على ميليشياتها فقط
كل عام 30 مليار دولار وهو ما يوازي
الموازنه السنويه لبلد مثل المغرب وضعف
مجمل مداخل تونس السنويه لضمان تدفق
الاموال اقرت طهران نظاما ماليا يختلف عن
باقي الدول ميزانيه ثانيه في بلد واحد
الاولى ميزانيه عامه للدوله تدفع بها
الرواتب وتمول الوزارات من خلالها بما في
ذلك وزاره الدفاع اما الثانيه ميزانيه
موازيه
حصرا للحرس الثوري ومؤسسات المرشد
المفارقه ان الموازنه الثانيه التي تمول
الحرس الثوري تفوق ضعفي الميزانيه المخصصه
للشعب بلغت هذا العام ثمانيه وستين مليار
دولار وهي بذلك تفوق ميزانيه الدفاع
الروسيه التي تخوض حربا في اوكرانيا بلغه
الارقام لم يبقى الكثير للشعب 80% من
الايرانيين حسب اخر الاحصاءات يقبعون تحت
خط الفقر الذي حدد ب 326 دولار للعائله
المتوسطه ثمان مرات اقل من رواتب ميليشيا
حزب الله نزاع اخرى رواتب الحرس الثوري
واستثمارات ذراعه الاقتصاديه خاتم
الانبياء معفيه من الضرائب السؤال عن
السبب قد يجلب المشاكل بدل الاجابات
بان مقر خاتم الانبياء لم يدفع ضرائب في
السنوات الخمس الماضيه يجب عليك تقديم
وثائق بهذا الخصوص يجب عليك تقديم الوثائق
والا من الممكن ان يتم مقاضاتك لا يمكنك
اتهام مؤسسه رسميه في هذا البلد بانها لا
تدفع الضرائب دون تقديم المستندات يجب
عليك تقديم المستندات بهذا الخصوص بعد هذا
الاجتماع والا سيوجه مكتب المدعي العام
اتهامات جنائيه لذا يرجى توخي الحذر